president-elect joe biden meets today
with workers and small
business owners hurt by the pandemic's
economic impact
the next president is urging congress to
pass a new covet relief bill
congress is under new pressure to
approve additional aid before the end of
the year as
ed o'keefe reports president-elect joe
biden is signaling that he supports a
new bipartisan push to pass a coveted
relief bill before the end of the year
but that it's just a start my transition
team is already working on
what i'll put forward in the next
congress to address the multiple crises
we're facing
about a dozen democrats and republicans
support a new 908 billion dollar
compromise
with more funding for small businesses
and unemployment benefits in a crisis
the people expect congress to act but
it's not supported by house speaker
nancy pelosi
nor senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell he's pushing his own
smaller proposal there's likely to be a
discussion about
additional some additional package of
some
size next year and there's been no
discussion between mcconnell and the
president-elect
who formally introduced his top economic
advisors on tuesday
help is on the way among them former
federal reserve chair
janet yellen now we're facing historic
crises again poised to be the first
woman
to lead the treasury department it's an
american tragedy
and it's essential that we move with
urgency
and as the president-elect continues
filling out his team cbs news has
confirmed
that the transition office is preparing
to meet soon with the leaders of civil
rights organizations including the naacp
and the urban league who are
increasingly concerned about the lack of
diversity
in some of the president-elect's top
positions a transition spokesman points
out that mr biden has already announced
several historic and diverse picks
as he did on tuesday and that his
success in building a diverse team
will be clear when our full slate of
appointees and nominees
is complete the pressure is coming from
black asian latino
even gay rights groups saying that given
the support that these groups gave to
the democratic ticket in november
they deserve seats at the table not just
the deputy or assistant level positions
but in top cabinet positions as well
latino leaders are pushing to have
five latino cabinet members in the new
biden administration
so far he's only named one tony and when
we talk about pressure ad i hope there
is pressure on this congress before they
go home for the holidays
to reach that compromise because there
are a lot of people in need right now
and a lot of governors looking to
restrict this or that for public health
but don't want to do it because it's
going to hurt the economy in their
states people need that support
so ed thank you very much we appreciate
it